this week marked the first 500 days of
donald trump's presidency or what i like
to call the first 500 days of donald
trump's presidency i celebrate a little
each day
here's tape that's me 500 days 500 days
since the media's nervous breakdown
began a lot of stuff happened since then
especially for you in your life that's
what matters
not us you and no matter what the media
says life went on without the predicted
catastrophes your life either stayed the
same or it got better and if it got
worse i blame obama but terrible people
terrible people
but even if nothing changed that's not
what was predicted the trumpets of doom
warned of financial meltdowns civil wars
and nuclear armageddon instead we have
peaceful prosperity lower taxes a real
chance with north korea a booming
economy and as an added bonus Kathy
Griffin went stoned bonkers thank you
thank you mr. crumb it's an incredible
age all right even if the media can't
see it or refuses to so if this is how
the media acts
imagine how they would be acting if
things were actually bad
really hates phones in the middle of all
this good news the media they search for
bad they're like those pigs that dig for
truffles except there's the press and
those truffles there are the stories
like where's Milania
oh there's Milania never mind about
Milania meanwhile you shrug the media
complaining about how the news create
unease that's like a mosquito
complaining about malaria a fruit bat
whining about rabies a rockstar
deploring chlamydia the media spreads
the malaise now clearly they got a
report on bad stuff but isn't it obvious
how frequently they avoid the good and
then they have the nerve to run stories
saying that bad news makes you sick no
it's not bad news that makes you sick
it's you are bad news that hurts
with each negative story paint you the
viewer as the villain is the climate
warming it's your fault you selfish
consumer rising inequality it's you evil
capitalist Pig there's an earthquake in
Peru it's cause you're fat
frankly it's not good for America being
told
hourly that America sucks if only there
was a solution for this and a solution
that somehow involves a dolphin racist
earthier yes they admit the people who
vote all the people who voted for Donald
Trump yes we live in a culture that
hates women just pizza this is
depressing the world is terrible and
it's all my fault the polar bear
population has declined for the fourth
year in a row and yes it is all your
fault Tom what yeah you Tom Shalu you
heard me
all this bad news is your fault you're
destroying the earth and you're a
heartless bigot in short you suck and
you're a horrible human being
man I feel sick great then I've done my
job sounds like someone needs an it's
not your fault dolphin do I even want to
know what that is the it's not your
fault Oakland is a normal sized dolphin
that has been genetically altered to the
size of a person and given legs so when
you find yourself sick from all the
world's bad news we'll be there to
remind you otherwise like during your
morning commute thank you well when a
co-worker tries to bum you out if you're
still driving to work you obviously keep
the planet it's not your fault it's not
your fault
or even when you least expect it wow
that sounds annoying but I guess it
beats all the sickness and sadness so
get the it's not your fault often today
order now we'll throw in a free it's
going to be okay shark
I just collect just let management know
no drugs were taken when we came up with
that idea so everything is viewed with
the same filter born from academia which
now infects news and entertainment and
it creates only one conclusion that you
are the oppressor if that doesn't make
you sick it should because right now if
you look around things are pretty good
we now have more jobs available than we
have jobless I've never heard of that
before that sounds like good news right
MSNBC
every fair
bottom line the media trying to diagnose
what's really at fault can only be done
with a mirror they need to look at it
and not just use it to do lines off the
media is the progressive hammer the
media is the progressive hammer and
anything that appears successful to them
becomes a nail no wonder we all have
headaches